the whole parent thing is so challenging  for me it's love your parents appreciate  your parents know why they're scared  they love you so much they're scared but  in the micro you can't live for your  parents validation as a grown-up it's  only going to lead to resentment you're  either going to have small friction now  or a very big friction later the amount  of people that wake up at 45 and deeply  resent their parents because they tried  to appease their parents for the last 20  years is very high and then sometimes  it's not even your parents sometimes  it's an older sibling sometimes it's  random strangers and social media  there's like so many things that people  try to validate for but i think  everybody knows the answer of who they  actually are even when you're not great  at self-awareness you are very tapped  into self-interest people are very clear  on their self-interest most people just  don't want to say it out loud